لم تنجلي بعد اعمده الدخان عن احياء دنيتك
ولا رائحه البارود
اترك المشهد هنا ان حال مدينه ليس بافضل
حال فالحرب لم تنتهي بعد ولم تنتهي معها
ماساه اناس قد يفقدون حياتهم او اعز ما
يملكون لدى سقوط اي قذيفه
وليس حال هذا الرجل العجوز بافضل من حال
مدينته
ملامحه
تحكي يوميات حرب افقدته الهدوء الذي يبحث
عنه وهو في اخر مراحل حياته وافقدته ما هو
اكثر احتياجا له اليوم
بعد هذا القصف فقدت رجليه هذه السياره
التي تشاهدونها ودمرت هي رجل التي اتحرك
بها فانا لا استطيع التحرك بدونها وانا
اوكراني لكنني تعبت من هذه الحرب
لم تكن صدفه ان تكون دنيتك هدفا يوميا فهي
على خط التماس جبهات القتال بين القوات
الروسيه والاوكرانيه من الى
وتسجل اكثر الهجمات بمدينه دنيتك على
احيائي كييفكي
ولا تستثنى كذلك
مدنوفاكا من القصف اليومي
لهذا المكان الذي نقف فيه الان فهو مفتوح
على جبهه
لكن على بعد كيلومترات قليله من هنا يحاول
الاهالي خلق فضاء بعيد عن اجواء الحرب
هنا عند الاصيل يتغير كل شيء يحاول هؤلاء
ولو للحظه تناسي انهم يعيشون في لجه حرب
دروس وربما يريدون استحضار ذكريات دونيت
كالجميله لعلها تبعث في قلوبهم قليلا من
الامل بغد افضل وتخفف عنهم هاجس القصف
اليومي
احاول ان انسى ما يحدث بمحيطنا لقد فقدت
عائلتي بيتنا في القصف ناتي الى المطاعم
وهي المكان الوحيد المتاح لنا ان لم افعل
ذلك فقد اصاب بالجنون فنحن بشر ونريد ان
نعيش
امام الناس للبقاء في الشارع فالمدينه
اعتادت ان تودع اهلها في وقت مبكر وتنتظر
دنيتك شروق يوم جديد
ويحدوها الامل بغروب صوت الحرب
ارض غير الجزيره دنيا